à la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
des yvelines la cpam
une visite des coulisses d'une feuille
de soins papier est organisé son délai
moyen de traitement est d'environ 20
jours en 2018 une plateforme en ligne de
recueil d'idées a été ouverte pendant
trois mois autour de divers thèmes
cela a permis de recueillir près de 300
idée d'assurer blinois dans les grandes
villes mais aussi dans la campagne on si
je vends mes grands parents
la difficulté c'est l'accès au soin et
je pense qu'un service public à une
mission aussi de pouvoir localiser des
médecins de proximité petit des
spécialistes pour apporter ses services
de santé même si les documents reçus par
voie postale sont minoritaires les
visiteurs ont pu découvrir lors de la
visite que c'est un flux important pour
la cpam une gestion optimale est
obligatoire près de 1000 onces encore
aujourd'hui du papier je m'attendais à
trouver quand même des choses un peu
plus dématérialisé que ça les assurés
ont pu échanger sur la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie de demain le
traitement d'une feuille de soins papier
coûte 1 euro
74 contre 27 centimes pour la version
électronique l'assurance maladie des
yvelines estime qu'on pourrait
économiser plus de 3,8 millions d'euros
par an le papier représente à peu près 6
% de notre activité
mais ces 6 % d'activité c'est quand même
144 millions de documents reçus tous les
jours donc c'est en fait très conséquent
effectivement il ya un enjeu fort à
pouvoir dématérialisée au maximum ses 6
% qui restent au delà des économies la
dématérialisation permet aux patients -
de démarches un meilleur délai de
remboursement
la cpam des yvelines envisage de
réaliser des consultations régulières
auprès des assurés